how do I find an internship if you are
young if you're just starting out if you
want to learn about an industry one of
the best ways to do it is to become an
intern at a company that you respect
that you look up to that you want to
emulate and figure out is this path for
you or not I always encourage young
people to try as many things as possible
so you don't get locked into one thing
too early you have to find what your
life's passion is what your purpose is
and that comes from exploring a lot of
different options and not get too down
on yourself when you haven't found it
because a lot of people get locked into
something way too early and then they're
stuck the rest of their lives doing this
one thing and they end up hating it more
and more and more and wishing they had
some other option when you're young you
have the ability to try all these things
out before you have you know burdens
before you have responsibilities before
you have to you know a spouse kids house
mortgage all those things to worry about
now is your time go out explore learn
what you are meant to do and if it
doesn't work out at some position three
months six months leaving go to
something else it's okay to bounce
around now how do you get that
internship it's a question I got from
one of my YouTube viewers Berta
thank you guys I love getting the
questions on YouTube Berta wrote to say
I'm a marketing student I'm trying to
find an internship and marketing
consultancy
I love branding and basically it goes on
but basically has not been able to find
an internship for one of the companies
she's looked at and one of my advice on
how to go and get this internship so
here's what I would do if I was trying
to get an internship I would first look
at the ideal companies that I want to
work for and where are you going to get
the most learning opportunity okay if
you're doing it just for a resume then
the bigger companies look better but if
you're doing it to really learn you're
going to get much more hands-on
experience working for a smaller company
because the big companies don't really
value their interns too much you're
going to be doing pretty boring jobs
you'll be learning a little bit and
you'll get the name on the resume but
you're not going to really increase your
skills and in my opinion if you're going
to take a job if you're going to go work
for somebody else
you want to do something where you're
going to learn something you're not
doing it for the money you're not doing
it for the resume you're doing it to
learn and so the best opportunities will
come with the smaller companies and the
smaller companies may not even have an
internship program here's the thing I
look at look for any entrepreneur look
for a company that you respect maybe ten
employees around that size so they're
not just starting up but they're doing
some amazing work and they're small
enough that if you join them you'll have
a ton of work to do every entrepreneur
has tons of work that they would love to
give to somebody tons they are
struggling they are they are in way over
their heads they are working crazy
number of hours they need reliable
people that they can count on and if
you're looking for even you said a free
internship that's something that people
would scoop up so I try to find an
entrepreneur that you look up to is
doing some amazing work that you one day
might want to emulate have your own
marketing consultancy company and making
that you know ten people plus type of
business find them out and contact them
let them know what you're doing just
like this passion email you sent me here
on YouTube because they may not even
thought of an internship program but
they are always looking for people who
are talented passionate and want to
learn and once you get in once you go
meet them let them know why you want to
do this what you hope to accomplish
because not enough employees are
passionate enough about the work that
they're doing if you come in with
passion excitement for marketing for
branding you're going to blow them away
especially if it's free to start they're
going to be crazy for not hiring you
that's your first step once you get in
you want to learn as much as you can
about the business you want to be
mentored by the entrepreneur you want to
take on as many projects as you can and
you're going to figure out if this
business is for you or not and don't
don't accept just a project they give
you ask for more no employee asks for
more right nobody asks to do more than
what they're given this is your chance
to stand out to shine to really learn
the business and if you're doing a great
job they're going to be fools not to
hire you not to want to turn this into a
full-time position for you and that's
going to be a pretty fortunate position
for you to be in and you'll discover is
this the business that you want to learn
from or not if it is you continue on if
it's not
go in turn somewhere else different
business if an industry and that's okay
until you figure out what you're born to
do so I would continue on my path if you
really need that resume just the name
keep going after the big companies who
have formal programs that's okay but I
think you're going to get a lot better
education and a lot better personal
development working for a smaller
company who doesn't even have an
internship program and you can be the
first person to join them this is one
quick aside I never had a huge
internship program I don't even think of
the concept and a school came to me and
said we'd like to do an internship
program with you
I thought that's a really cool idea and
one of the first people that came in was
a guy named Addis who was from Holland
and he came to Canada where I am and
needed a job opportunity so it was it
was a free internship and he became one
of my programmers to help out and
designing my website programming
designing the website and he was great
and he hustled and he worked and and I
felt the passion when I first met him
and it continued and I hired him and
he's still with me now and this is maybe
six seven years later he's still on the
team he's still developing new stuff for
the website and so if you show your
passion and your excitement to an
entrepreneur who has that same passion
excited who wants to build something
special you could be a key part of
helping them get to the next step
they're gonna want to bring you on board
and if you do a great job and prove
yourself and ask for more work and pour
yourself into this they're going to want
to hire you and you get to choose if you
want to stay at that company or not a
great position to be in believe those
you're watching like the video please
give a thumbs up below it makes you
always want to do more for you and
please leave a comment below let me know
what you think if you have a question
for your company let me know I'll make a
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon
you